[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
einen leckeren mandarin schmandt kuchen
also ein klassiker und erteilt den super
schnell ihr braucht keine großartigen
maschinen dafür
und wenn er fertig ist der kuchen dann
habt den super cremigen und saftigen
streuselkuchen mit den boden und auch
für die streusel benötigen wir nur einen
einzigen tag und der besteht aus 350
gramm mehl 130 gramm weiche butter 150
gramm braunem zucker oder auch weißen
eine packung backpulver und ein ei der
teig ist genial und einfach denn ihr
müsst einfach nur alle zutaten
miteinander vermischen und am ende
erhaltet ihr eine bröselige masse und
das ist auch richtig so
[Musik]
ich verwende hierzu meinen handwechsel
aber das geht auch genauso gut mit dem
schneebesen oder mit einem kochlöffel
oder sogar mit den händen wenn ihr euren
krümeligen tag jetzt mit den händen
zusammendrückt dann merkt ihr dass es
auch schön fest bleibt falls sie ein
sehr kleines ei verwendet dann könnt ihr
noch ein schluck milch dazugeben
anschließend führte ich meine 26 cm
springform mit back translate und kleide
den boden mit backpapier aus dort kommt
jetzt die hälfte unseres vorbereiteten
text hinein und wird mit den händen
schön flach angedrückt
und bis zur weiterverarbeitung kommt die
springform jetzt erstmal in den
kühlschrank
für die füllung benötigen wir 800 gramm
schmandt vier dosen mandarinen 40 gramm
stärke oder eine packung puddingpulver
und 80 gramm zucker
[Musik]
zu meinem stand gebe ich jetzt noch die
stärke und den zucker und verrührt das
ganze beim handmixer und auch hier könnt
ihr statt des mixers auch ein
schneebesen benutzen
es sitzt es gebe ich noch die mandarin
dazu und durch die mixa werden sie etwas
kleiner verfügt und wer möchte dass sie
ganz bleiben der kann auch ein
schneebesen oder einen teixeira benutzen
danach nehme ich mir meine springform
aus dem kühlschrank und verteile die
komplette füllung darauf und zu guter
letzt werden darauf nur unsere streusel
verteilt
[Musik]
der kuchen kommt jetzt bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für 35 minuten in den
ofen
so sieht der fertige kuchen aus jetzt
musste er noch über nacht in den
kühlschrank und am nächsten tag zeige
ich euch den anschnitt der kuchen ist
für alle die's nicht so süß mögen aber
der ist dennoch sehr cremig um sehr
lecker hier seht ihr noch mal im
anschnitt
und wenn ihr das nächste mal wieder
vorbeischaut würde ich mich freuen
bis zum nächsten mal auf die cs kitchen
und abonnieren nicht vergessen